[Musik]
haile lieben na wie sieht's aus neujahr
macht ihr jetzt auch so eine
ernährungsumstellung oder möchte durch
gesunde ernährung oder vielleicht zu den
winterspeck ein bisschen abtrainieren
dann habe ich heute eine super idee für
euch was ihr zu mittag essen kochen
könnte was gesund ist lange satt hält
und eben perfekt ist falls jetzt eben
die ernährung so ein bisschen umstellen
möchte und es ist auch sehr stark
angefragt also das ganze letzte jahr
über wurde immer wieder ein paar kannst
du mal gesunde rezepte machen
natürlich gab es zwischendurch immer
gesunde rezepte aber heute ich bin super
gespannt wie das video an kommt heute
ist wirklich meine non-plus-ultra
gemüsepfanne dich selber immer total
gerne mache und hier sind jetzt die
zutaten die sind auch nicht schwer
einzukaufen die gibt's überall
hier haben wir kokosmilch und öl damit
sie gern neutrales öl
wir fahren habe ich gemüse heute nehme
ich zu kini möhren paprika
ich habe ich noch eine knoblauchzehe
dazu sage ich euch gleich was außerdem
was bei mir nie fehlen darf ich liebe
brokkoli habe ich hier schon gewaschen
und an gewürzen kurkuma curry dann habe
ich hier edel süßes paprikapulver
scharfe paprika flocken kreuzkümmel und
natürlich salz und pfeffer und es geht
auch schon los das gemüse könnt ihr auf
jeden fall bevor die pfanne erhitzen
noch vorbereiten das heißt schon klein
schnippeln ich bin dafür jetzt meinen
willen schneider dann sieht es am ende
auch richtig hübsch aus und dann gehe
ich an die pfanne erhitzen den herd
ich lasse erstmal knoblauch dünnsten
also knoblauch nie richtig heiß braten
sondern wirklich nur auf mittlerer stufe
diensten zusammen mit dem öl und danach
gehe ich das gemüse dazu und noch mal
ganz gut zum knoblauch ist es heute ein
weltwunder ich habe noch einige kleine
knoblauchzehe kühlschrank gehabt sonst
kann ich immer knoblauch da ich liebe
knoblauch also euch schreibe ich in die
video beschreibung dass ihr zwei
knoblauchzehen rein nehmen sollte finde
ich persönlich jetzt heute auch besser
so
jetzt habe ich das hier schon erledigt
und gibt etwas gemüse dazu und das könnt
ihr dann ganz einfach drei minuten lang
auch so ein bisschen andünsten
[Musik]
das kommt den letzten schritt meine
lieben kokosmilch dazu geben die gewürze
dazu und dann zusammen mit deckel
einfach nur so ungefähr 78 minuten
köcheln lassen vorausgesetzt ihr habt
euer gemüse auch in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten ist einfach mal schauen wie
dick oder dünn das ist und ob es dann
auch wirklich geil
[Musik]
und fertig ist die gesunde gemüsepfanne
in zehn minuten zubereitet und macht er
zum allerbesten bereich der passt
nämlich wirklich total gut dazu ich
mache ganz normalen reißt ihr könnt aber
auch gerne den typischen reis nehmen von
mir verlinke ich in die video
beschreibung genau so wie alle zutaten
natürlich alle mengenangaben alle
utensilien nicht benutzt habt ihr bei
mir im shop findet und schreibt mit
gerne in die kommentare was möchtet ihr
als nächstes sehen soll sie eine torte
werden oder wieder was gesundes
mittagessen inspiration für apps möglich
ist schon wieder alles schreibt ja auch
immer gerne rein ich richte mich da
super super gerne nach ansonsten lasst
es euch schmecken das ist wirklich total
köstlich das bekommt ihr geld teilweise
wirklich in restaurants für 12 13 euro
serviert
genau das haben wir damals auch
aufgestellt aber macht es einfach zu
hause
so jetzt ganz viel spaß kurzen blackout
gehabt so guten appetit und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten rezept videos schießen
die beim unterstellte abonniert
einzuläuten
das also hat
[Musik]